subtil bonsoir un champ bien frais
laurent baffie chanter et vous vous êtes
la fille du grand champion cycliste
jacques anquetil le rival du fameux
raymond poulidor de notre enfance poupou
l'éternel second
c'est vrai que vous avez dit poupou
avant de dire papa pratiquement
pratiquement j'étais bien j'étais fan
des miettes à 10 po po avant 9 heures
alors pour leader était jamais premier
pourquoi il avait un mauvais dealers ou
quoi non non je pense que il y en a bien
qui était plus fort que lui au dessus
non sans doute alors sophie vous publié
aujourd'hui chez grasset un livre qui
s'appelle pour l'amour de jacques c'est
une histoire absolument incroyable qu'on
va prendre dès le début et calmement il
vaut mieux oui alors quand jacques
anquetil rencontre sa femme jeanine elle
est mariée à un médecin qui est l'ami de
jacques anquetil qui est un petit peu le
celui qui le suit non bah disons que
c'est son médecin et en même temps je
pense que fin juin quand il est fasciné
par en fait la classe sociale qu'il
représente et l'homme en lui-même qu'un
homme un peu de science était très
passionné par par la science la nature
donc il est fasciné par ces notables
normand qui en plus sont médecins donc
les deux hommes s'apprécient de son
rapport et la femme de ce notable
normande ce médecin qui deviendra madame
jacques anquetil est une très très jolie
femme vraiment quelle forme martine
carol inquiète vraiment blonde comme ça
très très jolie elle a deux enfants avec
ce médecin est là annie et alain voilà
et jacques anquetil votre père tombe
raide amoureux de cette femme il est
fasciné par l au départ elle n'est pas
elle n'est pas du tout intéressé au
départ par non elle ne parle que comme
un petit un petit paysan un peu un peu
péquenots comme elle dit en fait
et puis un jour elle est en vacances
avec ses deux enfants à villefranche et
là elle cède à ses venues en fait ça a
duré plusieurs années on partait souvent
en vacances ensemble et puis petit à
petit elle a appris à l'apprécier et
puis elle a succombé on va dire à son
charme
voilà elle couche avec lui elle dit au
petit matin le lendemain matin je savais
que j'aimerais jacques totalement
jusqu'à la mort belle histoire
alors voilà donc au début c'est une
passion clandestine entre jeanine et
jacques anquetil
ensuite il divorce il ya quand même des
péripéties au moment du divorce le
toubib séquestre sa femme à un moment
non oui enfin c'est disons qu'il faut
remettre aussi dans le contexte des
années afin de faire des années 50 début
des années 60 où c'était en fait ça se
faisait pas je veux dire les gens de
divorcer pas en plus bon c'était pour
aller avec un homme public enfin c'est
un truc c'est ce à quoi je veux dire
alors les enfants restent avec leur père
au départ chez le médecin et puis
comment sa fugue y est allé de plus en
plus souvent dans la maison de jeanine
et jacques et ils finissent par vivre
avec leurs mains et leur beau père
disons que leur père finit par capituler
devant devant l'insistance des enfants à
toujours vouloir en fait ces terres
étaient fascinés par par la vie qu'avait
qu'avait ce couple en fait qui était
déjà très beau et en plus qui voyagent
et qui les emmenait de partout à travers
le monde donc en fin des années 60
voyager au bout du monde s'était pas
commun heureusement là le tout lui coupe
les ponts et on le reverra plus jamais
donnera plus jamais de nouvelles voilà
ça c'est fin du premier épisode est ce
que tu suis laurent oui toubib jeanine
toubib deux enfants jacques anquetil
voilà tu suis les notes tu suis mia
alors ça c'est fin du premier épisode et
bien ensuite quand jacques quand ils
arrêtent le vélo au début des années 70
il a aidé à 36 ans et puis d'un seul
coup il se retrouve tout seul dans sa
grande propriété du château des elfes
700 hectares et là d'un seul coup il se
rend compte qu'il a fait une carrière
formidable qu'il a fait du bon travail
en tant que coureur cycliste mais qui
n'a pas de descendance il n'a pas
d'enfant
il va en avoir tout à fait en fait il
était en plus c'était un homme qui était
fasciné par par le miracle de la nature
c'était quelque chose mais bon il était
fou des bébés il adorait les enfants et
puis toi ça fabuleux le fait de mettre
au monde et ce qu'il faut savoir ce qui
est très important c'est que elle a deux
enfants par césarienne deux
accouchements très difficile et son
médecin en fait façon mon mari pardon de
médecins lui à ligaturer les trompes
estimant que c'était dangereux pour elle
et sa santé d'avoir d'autres enfants
donc il ne peut pas avoir d'enfant avec
jeanine et il est très embêté parce
qu'ils l'aiment et
10 faut que je trouve une mère porteuse
c'est la seule solution et à un moment
il pense même aller voir une prostituée
dit on va prendre une [ __ ]
a paris il est prêt à partir à paris
pour chercher quelqu'un est près
n'importe quoi pour trouver quelqu'un
voilà alors évidemment à ce moment-là
jeanine et tourmenté elle se dit quand
même c'est incroyable qu'on mari soit
obligé de faire ça elle cherche et puis
petit à petit une idée vient
insidieusement comme ça en elle ça
serait l'idée de donner sa fille annie à
jacques anquetil
oui d'accord et oui elle demande à sa
fille de karité gb team sky à l'âge où
je suis né ben voilà elle veut qu'il
soit heureux
elle se dit en fait que disons pour
avoir un enfant au plus près d'elle
quelque part ça devient comme une
évidence pour elle que y'a que sa fille
qu'est capable enfin disons que c'est le
mieux parce que s'adresse vraiment à la
maison devant la prison et et ccc fois
ce moment pour moi c'est magnifique
c'est un don extraordinaire ce qui veut
dire quand même c'est que annie votre
mère donc n'accepte pas sous la
contrainte on ne force pas il faut dire
les choses quand même un lui en parler
lui à lui demandait ce que tu
accepterais c'est une mission en fait
c'est une mission de procréation calé au
départ 20,7 au départ mais je pense que
dès le début elle a toujours été
fascinée par lui quand elle était petite
elle était admiratif de l'homme en plus
bon c'est fâcheux c'est un très bel
homme donc elle a pas de difficulté à
succomber à son charme
alors ce qu'il faut dire évidemment
c'est que votre mère annie n'était pas
la fille biologique déjà qu'en est il
donc à pas il n ya pas d un crs en même
temps comme il l'a fait quand même car
moralement
oui c'est un petit peu incestueux parce
qu'ils aiment ou hélène quoi oui un
petit peu
voilà c'est un peu incestueux quand même
parce qu'il avait il avait élevé oui
c'était sa petite fille sans mains forme
pas sur le fond oui mais voilà alors
voilà donc vous retrouver vous avec deux
mamans dont l'une est la fille de
l'autre alors au milieu de ça voilà
alors au début jacques anquetil se dit
on va faire reconnaître la maternité
djahnine par l'administration mais ça
marche pas non mais c'est à dire qu en
fait au départ
à l'époque quand je suis né chine en 71
et la loi pour reconnaître ces enfants
naturels et patient 72 parce que ça
l'embêtait beaucoup que je ne porte pas
son nom qu'il avait envie de me faire un
peu passé pour
pour la fille de sa femme ce qui n'a pas
pu être possible parce qu'à dix quand
même faut pas exagérer et l'année
d'après il m'a reconnu et j'ai porté son
voilà alors ça aurait pu en rester là
c'est à dire que si à ce moment là votre
mère annie était parti faire sa vie aux
autres par serez pu en rester là mais le
problème c'est qu'au delà de cette
mission de procréation votre mère reste
dans le lit de jacques anquetil voilà
ils sont pas restés juste le temps de
faire le môme
ils sont restés 12 ans dans le même lit
et le soir jacques anquetil commencé la
nuit dans le lit de 2 annie la maman de
sophie et ensuite il rejoignait le lead
jeanine la maman danny way je vais faire
un chaînon c mais tout ça se passe très
bien ce qu'il faut dire quand même
sophie n'y a pas de voie là ya pas de
violence tout ça c'est bien
non enfin - ya toujours des petits c'est
à dire je pas dans un couple il ya des
fois des
déjà des petites tensions donc à trois
c'est plus compliqué mais non dans
l'ensemble
yacine jalousie un peu de merfy ça se
passe bien quoi je veux dire c'est pas
c'est pas un truc il se dispute pas tous
les jours qu'on va tout va bien il ya
des fois des petites engueulades mais ma
foi comme partout dans tout couple c'est
à dire 12 ans cette espèce de vie comme
ça dure 12 ans et un moment votre mère
quand même rencontre quelqu'un qui lui
dit mme enfin la vie c'est pas ça à
disons le temps passe et puis elle voit
en fait les elle voit sa jeunesse un peu
partir elle voyait là elle a toujours
vécu sous l'emprise en fait de son beau
père et de sa mère et un moment donné
elle a besoin de deux vis à vis à vis
donc elle décide de partir mais c'est la
première qui a su dire non je m'en vais
à ajax est difficile de dire non à
jacques anquetil parce que c'était
facile et souvent dans votre lit
d'ailleurs c'était insultes orientale
quoi c'est quelqu'un dont on avait du
mal à apa observez les ordres et
quelqu'un qui était très ouvert qui
accepte facilement la conversation mais
il était dans la subtilité on va dire il
arrivait avoir tout fait l'arrivée
toujours à ses fins un sens qu'on ait
l'impression que ça soit lié qu'il ait
voulu mais bon voilà d'arriver à ses
fins quand tu les cages à quand il ne se
remet pas du départ d'annie devient
malade d'amour quoi d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être ça qui lui a filé sans son
cancer j'en sais rien mais toujours est
il que c'est de ça dont il mourra
quelques années plus tard hélas jeanine
sa femme demande alain son fils et à sa
femme dominique de venir habiter avec
eux enfin pas habiter nanterre qui se
voyait plus trop parce que
annie ne s'entendait pas bien avec
dominique ça sert de colonne mais c'est
face il y avait une gomme et des feutres
à ce moment là jeanine donc demande à
son fils alain et à sa femme dominique
de venir vivre près de sessa enfin c'est
pas de vivre et de cirque au départ on
habitait tous ensemble et ma mère en
fait ne dit encore dominique est arrivé
à la maison ça a été quelque part une
forme de trou entre travailler parce que
bon déjà elle était de une troisième set
ça faisait un peu compliqué à gérer tout
le monde sous le même toit et elles se
sont disputés en fait est que mon oncle
est partie vivre de l'autre côté de
rouen à ce moment là donc anctil se sert
de dominique prendra ni jalouse et
poissy de la faire revenir
ouh la la série suit quand ma mère 120
nanou en fait tu décides de recréer un
million de dire à son fils de revenir
plus souvent à la maison puisque en fait
annie n'est plus là pour la nominant de
rentrée j'allais la lino et parce qu'on
a peur on l'appelle tout cela nous en
fait c'est c'est un petit nom qu'elle
entre nous et est donc elle ramène son
fils à la maison et sa belle fille qui
viennent régulièrement alors il n'est
plus du tout hélas germe une idée
extraordinaire dans la tête de mon père
très tacticien de dire bah finalement
pour embêter annie je vais peut-être
m avec dominique ce qui manque pas de
faire ce qu'ils voient là mais alors
mis à les y aller
non ton oncle wii qui en même temps
ton frère toute justice yeux c'est vrai
qu'au niveau des titres c'est une
embrouille total en bout au total à dire
que mon oncle et mon frère enfin c'est
mon demi-frère quelque façon mon frère
par le titre c'est mon parrain en plus
donc c'est un peu con tu n'étais pas
jaloux que la meilleure solution
car la bombe et non avec à granby ça va
quoi mr c'est une histoire une histoire
absolument incroyable puisque donc
anctil après avoir été avec la mère de
sophie se met avec la femme du frère de
sophie avec dominique et il a un enfant
encore il en enfant qui est votre frère
christopher christopher voilà et donc
avec mes cousins germains jeune frère en
commun
benjamin c'est le prénom c'est le degré
de parenté là il faut ordonner
absolument extraordinaire malgré tout ça
malgré la naissance de ce christopher
jacques anquetil ne renonce pas à annie
et elle dit un jour bon bah je reviens
6,7 dominique s'en va immédiatement et
alors lui lui dit non et dit non non je
vais attendre d'abord le baptême de
christopher donc elle revient pas sinon
elle serait revenue à votre mère avec
des 6e
donc voilà et c'est la veille du baptême
de christopher qui découvrira qu'il a un
cancer voilà ça c'est des pilotes de
l'histoire
donc il a il a attendu ce baptême la
haie et la veille la prends cette triste
nouvelle
et c'est dominique ce qu'il faut dire
quand même je la connais pas mais enfin
elle s'occupera lui jusqu'à sa mort
quand oui non bien sûr elle accompagnera
jusqu'au bout je pense qu'elle a été
très amoureuse de lui aussi aussi bien
sûr toutes les femmes mais énormément de
monde mais ça fait un enfant à clé
badens est dans la danse et jean jaurès
à 13 ans la médecine je voulais anticipé
j'aime bien une question oui est ce que
est ce que ton père donc est ce qu'il
avait dans son coeur assez d'amour pour
donner à tout le monde pour que tout le
monde soit cloud sommes aujourd'hui
condé double vie avec des maîtresses et
quand je pense au sénégal a donné à tout
le monde quoi partir l'homme pour moi
est foncièrement bigame à la base il ya
du poggio elle vient tous les gars ça
pas été facile pour vous ça quand même
été une enfance un petit peu compliqué
non l'enfance non parce que toute ma
petite enfance a été génial enfin je
veux dire deux mamans c'est top c'est
doublement d'amour si on peut jouer si
vous saviez vous savez la vérité quand
même toujours su mais c'est vrai que
j'ai faim j'ai on se rappelle pas quand
est ce qu'on a appris à marcher et moi
je me rappelle un j'ai toujours su qu'il
était ma mère ma grand mère ça jamais
été cachés mais je veux dire c'est un
homme qui a eu finalement le courage de
mettre sa femme et sa maîtresse sous le
même toit et faire ça avec beaucoup
d'amour et dans une entente
extraordinaire vous accepteriez bien ça
je pense que si si oui effectivement si
un homme a vraiment cette générosité du
coeur que je me sens pas lésés que
by et que vraiment il a ce charisme qui
fait kim envoûte et qui me donne
satisfaction
je pense que oui je pense qu'on peut en
plus c'est l'histoire de madame oui
c'est sympa si des hommes seraient
capables d'accepter inverse
en tous les cas à vous si vous n'êtes
pas spécialement perturbé en tous les
cas vous avez l'air plus tôt plutôt cool
mais vous êtes quand même partie un
petit peu en amérique latine un pilot
mexique à un moment oui enfin je suis
partie non mais ça c'était enfin disons
qu'après je me suis un peu cherché mais
comme toute personne peut chercher un
moment donné bon voilà on suit son
chemin c'est vrai qu'il ya des moments
plus ou moins difficiles vont mal à
l'adolescence n'a pas été facile parce
que d'avoir sa tante qui devient du jour
au lendemain sa belle mère quand on est
en pleine crise d'adolescence de perdre
son père à 16 ans et demi bon c'est pas
c'est pas l'idéal quand même mais mais
sinon sur tout le reste non j'ai
vraiment été très heureuse quoi
aujourd'hui ça va vous vivez bien je vis
encore dans un endroit magnifique
au bout du monde battus quand même c'est
ça faire un croquis de la corse avec
avec joël c'est ça et vous avez un
enfant ça s'appelle yann et qui a 6 ans
je vais gagner le papa policier
important
non ok alors ce qui est tout de même
bien le plus incroyable de l' affaire
c'est qu'un âne ou jeannine vie là bas
aussi dans son ensemble
aussi à 3 km vous avez recréer ça là-bas
tout à fait le clan sa reconstitution
qui avoue il ya votre maman et retourne
et votre grand mère là c'est ça elles
ont elles ont lu le bouquin
oui bah elles ont toutes eu avant
dominique aussi du reste avant de rendre
le sortir même j'aurais aimé leur avis
qu'elles n'ont pensé moi j'étais
d'accord
bah ouais enfin ils ont trouvé dominé
qu'elle a gardé la propriété elle quand
même c'est mon frère moi qui aime allah
non c'est non attends maintenant c'est
plutôt peu à part dont la maison est
alors quel vélo tu n'as pas parce que
moi j'en fais pas du vélo et ce qui est
incroyable c'est que ça a pas laissé
beaucoup de traces finalement c'est un
peu comme je sais pas si vous avez vu le
bouquin de franz olivier giesbert ces
belles l'américain le vacon des choses
terribles qui lui sont arrivées pendant
son enfance et son adolescence et
finalement il en est sorti assez indemme
bizarrement mais c'est pas je pense pas
que c'est bizarre je veux dire il ya des
gens qui manquent d'amour dans plein de
choses moi j'ai eu énormément d'amour
donc je pense qu'il ya de l'amour dans
quelque chose quelque part on se
rééquilibre jeudi il n'y a pas de on
peut avoir des moments de déséquilibre
mais l'amour est plus fort que tout vous
saviez depuis toujours que vous
raconterai cette histoire un jour
quelque part je l'avais en moi j'ai
toujours dit quand j'étais petit
un jour je raconterai cette histoire est
j'aime bien écrire donc bon l'un dans
l'autre et un moment donné est venu donc
après avoir vu un enfant peut-être
d'être bien stable avec tout le monde
autour de moi je me suis dit finalement
ça serait bien d'écrire ce livre déjà
pour me prouver à moi même que je suis
enfin que j'étais capable de le faire de
raconter ça et puis ça a été enfin il ya
eu des petits des petites choses que
j'ai entendu des fois des petits
dérapages de gens de l'extérieur qui se
permettait de dire qu avait eu vent ou
entendu des bruits sur ma situation
familiale
je me suis finalement s'il ya quelqu'un
qui a le droit de raconter cette
histoire c'est moi et je trouve que ce
n'est plus vrai que ce soit vous que
carrie parce que j'étais vraiment bien
sûr j'aimerais fait mal si c'était
quelqu'un d'extérieur qui l'avait
raconté déjà on peut pas la comprendre
si on n'est pas à l'intérieur et en plus
c'est quand même une très belle histoire
d'amour
mais ce qui est incroyable c'est que ça
soit ça soit pas sorti finalement c'est
quand même je lis une énorme star et
tout le charisme de l'homme
est ce que le cancer il a eu à cause du
dopage alors moi je vous réponds la
question suivante je ne sais pas ce
qu'est ce qu'un enfant de 8 ans qui aime
leucémie c'est à cause du dopage
je ne sais pas ouais le cancer entre
autres choses qui ne s'expliquent pas ça
se déclenche chez n'importe qui
n'importe comment est-ce que le dopage
aurait favorisé le démarrage du cancer
ça il en prenait un petit peu quand même
vous le dit d'ailleurs dans votre
bouquin il a été le première phase a été
le premier coureur ou matière a avoué
enfin dire que
on ne gagnait pas un tour de france avec
un morceau de sucre qui en a parlé
publiquement et il a dit si personne
n'en prenais je n'en prendrai pas est ce
que j'explique aussi d'en livrer mois le
dopage c'est sûr quand je vois ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est enfin c'est
triste quoi ça me fait mal au coeur ne
s'était pas du tout
la même chose à l'époque enfin c'était
beaucoup plus gentil on va dire vous
pensez qu'ils en pensent quoi si vous
voilà ce soir d'un je pense que quelque
part ça le ferait sourire
ouais ouais franchement l'ambiguïté du
personnage ce pays
moreau jacques gérault
j'ai passé
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus